- Welcome to a conversation with history.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is David Cole,
who is the national legal
director of the ACLU
and a professor at Georgetown
University Law Center,
a volunteer attorney
for the Center for Constitutional Rights,
the legal affairs
correspondent for The Nation,
and a regular contributor to
The New York Review of Books.
He is the author of 10 books,
and his books have
received multiple awards,
including the American Book Award
for Enemy Aliens: Double Standards
and Constitutional Freedoms
in the War on Terrorism.
His first book was No Equal Justice,
and his most recent book
is Engines of Liberty.
He has litigated many
significant constitutional cases
in the Supreme Court
and he is Berkeley's
2018 Jefferson Lecturer.
David, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thanks for having me.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Well, I was born in Princeton,
raised outside of New Haven, Connecticut,
and then in Evanston, Illinois,
but I've been on the East
Coast ever since college.
- And looking back, how did your parents
influence your thinking about the world?
- Well, my parents were deeply
interested in education.
My dad was an English professor,
first at Yale and then at Northwestern.
My mom was a public school teacher.
They were also deeply Catholic
and deeply liberal,
and so, I think, taught
me to care about ideas
and to care about education,
but mostly to care about the vulnerable
and to care about social justice.
- And what got you interested
in law and civil liberties?
- Well, I kinda backed into
law and civil liberties.
I went to Yale undergraduate,
and was an English major.
When I graduated, I thought I
wanted to become a journalist,
but I hadn't written for
the school newspaper.
I had written lots of
papers as an English major,
but I'd been on the swim team,
so you spend most of your time underwater.
So I thought, I'll try freelancing,
but I have to justify my existence
while I'm freelancing,
and one of the options
was continuing my liberal arts education
by applying to Yale Law
School, which I did.
It was the only law school I applied to,
'cause I had zero interest
in being a lawyer,
but I liked being in New Haven
and I heard that Yale Law School
was a way to continue a
liberal arts education, really.
I got wait-listed
and I made other plans,
and then the very end of the summer,
August 1980, I guess,
I got a call, I was actually in Colorado,
got a call from my mom, saying,
"The Yale Law School just called.
"If you can be there in a week,
"you have a space."
So I was clearly the last
person to get into that class.
Somebody at the last minute
must have pulled out,
they said, "How are we
gonna fill this slot?"
And then I went and I still didn't really,
I still had the view I
wanted to be a journalist.
I started writing for the Yale Daily News,
covering and doing theater reviews
and music reviews and film reviews,
'cause that was my passion.
I was interested in the classes,
but I didn't really think
I wanted to be a lawyer.
I took time off from law
school because I thought,
oh my God, I'm gonna graduate,
I'm gonna have to become a lawyer,
and I interned at the Atlantic
the first semester I took off,
and then I was gonna intern at The Nation
the next semester that I took off.
But in between that
time, I worked at a place
called the Center for
Constitutional Rights,
a non-profit law firm in New York,
and it transformed my view
and I said, "I wanna be a lawyer."
I called The Nation and said,
"I'm not gonna come and be your intern.
"I'm gonna stay and work
"for the Center for
Constitutional Rights,"
and indeed, that was my first job
after graduating and clerking.
- Well, you've just explained to us
why your 10 books are
so beautifully written.
- [David] Aw.
Well, thank you, thank you so much.
- Yeah, no, it's really true,
because for a layman,
it leads you into some really
important ideas in the law.
I like to ask my guests what they think
is a skillset and temperament
required for the kind of work they do,
in your case a lawyer, civil
liberties lawyer, and so on.
- Tenacity is important,
because these are long battles.
I never forget I took a case on in 1987,
a group of Palestinian immigrants
who were rounded up in early dawn raids
and locked up in high-security,
and alleged to be deportable,
not for having engaged
in any kind of criminal
or terrorist activities,
but for their affiliation
with a PLO group.
And I got involved in
the case at the outset,
and that case lasted for 21 years.
So it started under Ronald Reagan,
Ed Meese was the attorney general,
and it continued under George H.W. Bush.
It continued under Bill Clinton.
It continued under George W. Bush.
And ultimately in 2008 the
government finally gave up
and allowed our people to remain here.
So you gotta kind of keep
your eye on the long ball.
You also, I think, have to be...
Willing to see the other
side of an argument,
because to be effective,
either as a professor
or as an advocate, you
really can't just preach
your view of things,
you have to understand
what the opposing view is
and be able to meet its arguments.
And you only meet those arguments
if you take them seriously.
And so to be a good professor
you have to force your students
to meet the other side,
other side's arguments, and
to be an effective advocate,
either in the courts or in the legislature
or in the court of public opinion.
I think you have to take
the other side's arguments seriously
and really grapple with them.
- In your book, Engines of Liberty,
you say, describing the people
who are involved in political activism
which we'll talk about
in a minute, you say,
"There are defined by
principled commitment
"to particular ideals, and
they defend those ideals
"whether popular or not."
So that's another quality.
- Exactly.
And now, at the ACLU,
in some sense, we're
known for that, right?
We defended the rights of
the Nazis to march in Skokie.
We defended the right
of a white supremacist
to hold a rally in Charlottesville
that ended in terrible, terrible tragedy.
But we defend the rights
of all human beings.
We think they are human rights.
They vest in us because we are human.
They're not owned only by
people who we agree with.
And if you hold that view
and you hold that view
in a principled way,
then I think it's incumbent upon you
to fight for those principles
whether you agree or
disagree with the client.
We recognize this all the time
with criminal defense lawyers, right?
We don't think criminal defense lawyers
are advocating in favor of
murder, robbery, assault, rape.
They are defending individuals
who are accused of those
kinds of activities,
even many times when the individual
has actually committed those activities,
in defense of a certain set of rights,
rights that are owned to everybody
regardless of what they do
and regardless of their belief systems.
And the same thing is true
of the First Amendment.
So yeah, I've represented many people
with whom I don't agree,
but I think one of the fortunate things
I've had as a constitutional lawyer,
as a public interest
constitutional lawyer,
is that I have always been advocating
for values that I believe in.
Now, a lot of lawyers
essentially are hired guns.
They do the work of the
client who pays them
and their job is to advance those views
whether or they agree with them or not,
whereas I've had the luxury of essentially
being able to advocate for free speech,
for due process, for equal protection,
sometimes on behalf of
people I don't agree with,
but I always am committed to
the values that I'm advocating.
- One other aspect of your
writings that comes out
that relates to this skillset
is kind of an understanding of the law
in the context of the
broader political context.
Where does that come
from in your background,
and talk a little about that.
- So where does that come
from in my background?
I'm not sure.
I mean, my parents, as
I said, were liberal.
They were not particularly activists.
My mom was a kind of,
well, in some sense, she was an activist
in the sense of she always volunteered
for get out the vote drives.
The first time I saw a Barack Obama sign
was when he was running for
state senate in Illinois.
I came home and there it was.
I had never heard of this guy.
Who is this guy?
You got a sign up.
So she was active in that way,
but they weren't demonstrators
or activists of that kind.
You know, I think I
really came to this view,
I guess through a sense of,
first of all, I was a lawyer
that argued mostly in court.
But as I became a professor,
I became an advocate for
constitutional rights
and civil liberties in a variety of forms.
I was doing it in speeches and lectures,
like I'm doing here at Berkeley
at the Thomas Jefferson Lecture.
I was doing it in the courtroom
in continuing to litigate cases.
But I was also doing it in
the field of public opinion,
writing op-eds, writing
columns for The Nation,
for The New York Review of Books.
And then, several years ago,
I decided to take a look
at how constitutional law
really works in this country,
and that's what led ultimately
to the book Engines of Liberty,
which is an argument that in order
to understand constitutional law,
you can't just read the cases
and focus on what the courts have said
and what the lawyers before
the courts have argued,
which is basically what we
do in constitutional law
when we teach it in the classroom.
But that's a really
restricted understanding
of how the law develops, and in fact,
when you see any serious
development in constitutional law,
most of the work that is
done to reach that result
is done outside of the courtroom,
sometimes by lawyers but
often just by citizens,
citizens committed to a particular idea
and willing to work in
a variety of forums,
whether it's state
legislature, state courts,
city councils, universities,
religious groups.
I mean, one of the great
things about America
is, robust as democracy as we have,
is that there are so many forums.
And so if your argument
is not gonna prevail
in the Supreme Court of
the United States today,
then you don't bring a case
to the Supreme Court today.
But there's lots of other
forums you can choose.
- So before we talk
about your three books,
talk a little and briefly
about your role at the ACLU.
You've given some sense
of what it's doing,
but tell us a little about your role
as the chief attorney.
- Yeah, so I was hired to be
the national legal director
in the summer of 2016.
The national legal director
oversees all of our work.
We have 300 attorneys,
100 in the national office
and then 200 in the affiliates.
The ACLU has an affiliate
in every state, essentially,
in the United States, so we
have people on the ground
at the local level, but we also
have subject matter experts
at the national level.
And I oversee them all, in some sense,
but particularly the national legal staff.
Anything that goes to the Supreme Court
from the ACLU, a petition
for Supreme Court review
or opposing another side's
petition for Supreme Court review
or a merits case where
we represent a client
or an amicus brief, where we file a brief
in support of another case
in which we're not the principal lawyers,
those all come through my office.
I have to sign off on them, I edit them,
I strategize about what they ought to say,
approve them, and the like.
But the job has changed dramatically
from what I thought it was gonna
be when I accepted the job.
So think back to the summer of 2016.
I was recruited to this
job by Anthony Romero,
the executive director, who said to me,
said, "David, I've got an
offer you can't refuse.
"You've been practicing
constitutional law for 30-some years
"under a conservative
majority Supreme Court.
"Just think what it would be like
"to help run the ACLU and
run its Supreme Court docket
"under a liberal majority Supreme Court."
Because at that time of course
we all knew Hillary Clinton
was gonna win the presidency,
she was gonna name Justice
Scalia's successor,
and for the first time in four decades,
the court would have a liberal majority.
So I thought, wow, that's
a great opportunity.
I signed on the bottom line.
Didn't put in any what-if
because nobody thought
there'd be any what-if.
Obviously the job changed
dramatically on November 8th,
when President Trump was elected,
but in many ways it's a
much more important job now.
It's more defensive than it is offensive.
We are now putting out fires
as much as advancing new concepts
of constitutional rights and liberties.
But that's part of what we
are supposed to be about.
We are the ACLU, we
defend the Bill of Rights.
When those rights are
attacked, we are most needed.
I think one of the things
that I find really...
Buoying about this period
is the incredible citizen engagement
around civil rights and civil liberties
from the women's march
to the people who went out to airports
to demonstrate against
the Trump muslim ban
to the town halls about
the Affordable Care Act
and the like, and we see that at the ACLU.
So before Trump was elected,
we had 400,000 members.
Today we have 1.75 million members.
- That's quite a change
and quite a change in the environment.
Let's take you on a journey
through some of these ideas in your books.
Your first book was the one on
the criminal justice system,
No Equal Justice, and in that book
you raise an important
argument about structure.
In a way it's a theoretical explanation
of the old French saying
that the law is equal,
both the rich and the poor
can sleep under the bridge.
Explain why structure means that a system
that helps us understand a system
in which equality before the law,
even when attempts are
made to implement that,
comes out with different outcomes
because there's a privileged
part of the society
and then there's the very poor.
- Yeah, yeah.
So yeah, I took the
title, No Equal Justice,
from a quote from a Supreme
Court opinion that said
something like, there
can be no equal justice
as long as the kind of trial a man gets
depends on the amount of money he has.
And that is a core ideal of
our criminal justice system.
Everybody has the same rights,
the rights of criminal defendants.
Whether Fourth Amendment rights
with respect to investigations
and searches and seizures,
or Fifth Amendment rights with
respect to interrogations,
or Sixth Amendment rights,
which are the rights
that cover your right to a fair trial,
your right to a lawyer,
in that trial your right to
confront witnesses against you.
Those rights don't apply to the rich.
They apply to everybody.
They are across the board rights.
And, as the court said,
there can be no equal justice
as long as the kind of trial a man gets
depends upon the amount of money he has.
But of course, we know that
the kind of trial a man gets
depends upon the amount of money he has
because if you're poor, you
rely on a public defender
who often is very committed
and often very good,
but very overextended.
If you're rich, you can hire
the best lawyers in the country
and you can hire a big team
and they can spend incredible
resources defending you,
and you just get a very
different kind of justice.
So the argument of the book
is essentially that in name
these rights are equal,
but in practice, in the way they work,
we have adopted rules
and systems
that have the effect of
securing these rights
to the privileged,
but saving on the costs of these rights
by denying them, effectively,
to the underprivileged.
And what I mean by saving
on the costs of these rights
is that all these rights have costs.
Most of 'em, there's a cost
between protecting rights
and protecting our safety.
If we got rid of the
Fourth Amendment tomorrow,
if we said the police
could search your house
or your backpack or your car
without any probable cause,
without a warrant from a judge,
the police would have an
easier time catching criminals,
and they might keep us
more secure from criminals.
But we would be very
vulnerable to the state.
So there's a balance to be struck there.
The more you protect privacy,
the more you make it hard for
the police to do their job
in the interests of
protecting Americans' privacy,
the greater risk that
there will be more crime
that is not captured
and brought to justice.
And what I argue in the book
is that liberals tend to favor rights
and conservatives tend to favor
protection of public safety.
But in fact what we
have done in our system
is we have struck two balances.
The rich get their rights protected,
but we save on the costs
in terms of public safety
that extending those same
rights across the board
by denying them, effectively,
to the poor, to minorities, and the like.
And so you see that in things
like the right to counsel,
where, yeah, everybody
has a right to a lawyer
and you have a right to a
lawyer paid for by the state
if you can't afford one,
but in reality, the kind of resources
that we put behind engines of defense
are so limited that public defenders
and lawyers who defend the poor
are just incapable of
doing the kind of work
that they would need to do
to provide equal justice
to the kind of trial a man gets
when he has the money to pay for a lawyer.
- And you go on to argue that remedies,
one of the remedies
that one would look for
is building the communities
that the poor come from
so there could be
penalties such as shaming
that would be enforced by the community,
and thereby make the law more legitimate
to those communities.
- Yeah, well, I think,
and I guess I think two things.
I did talk about the
Japanese model, essentially,
which is to involve the community
in the punishment of someone
who has committed a crime,
and by the community they
mean the person's family,
the person's teacher or teachers,
the person's coach or coaches,
the person's religious minister,
anyone who plays an important
role in that person's life.
Involve them in sort of
the collective punishment
and condemnation of the individual
for what he did as wrong,
of the act he did as wrong,
but at the same time,
commit them to reintegrating
and helping this individual
move beyond that crime.
Whereas in our country, we
don't involve the community,
and we don't do much at
all to try to reintegrate,
and we just lock people
up and throw away the key.
And then once they get out,
'cause they do eventually get out,
they have no resources and nobody
to hold them up and support them.
I talked about that as one possible way
of responding.
I now believe, I guess, that
it's so much broader than that,
that really we ask the criminal
justice system too much
if we ask it to solve these problems.
'Cause these problems don't come
from the criminal justice system as such,
they come from the circumstances
into which people are born,
the vast disparities in
wealth and opportunity
that we have in this country,
and so if you grow up in a part of town
where most of the people don't have jobs
and where most of the people
don't have intact families
and where there's tremendous
drug and gang activity,
it's gonna be really
hard for you to make it.
And asking the criminal justice system
to solve that problem I
think is a real mismatch.
- In your book on Engines of Liberty,
you are looking at the
broader political context
in which the Constitution
changes over time.
And there are two case studies in there
that are quite different and
remarkable in their own way,
with both following the same journey.
One is gay marriage and
the other is gun rights.
Both involve significant individuals
who saw the problem from
their personal experience
and then went on this journey over time
to touch all the political bases in a way
to then change the Constitution.
Talk about gay rights first.
- So the basic idea of this book was:
how do you explain the fact
that marriage equality
went from unthinkable,
which is what it was 25, 30 years ago,
to inevitable, which
is what it was in 2015
when the Supreme Court
heard argument in the case?
There was no question
it was gonna come out
in favor of marriage
equality at that point.
How did that happen?
And similarly with gun rights,
Warren Burger, who was the
conservative Republican
chief justice of the Supreme Court,
said in 1991 that he thought the notion
that the Second Amendment
protects an individual right to bear arms
was one of the greatest frauds
perpetrated on the American people
by a special interest
group in his lifetime.
That was 1991.
Conservative Republican chief
justice of the Supreme Court.
The notion that the Second Amendment
protects the individual right
to bear arms is a fraud.
2008, the Supreme Court recognizes
an individual right to bear arms.
So how did those changes come about?
And in many respects, one is a right
as a conservative cause and
the other is a liberal cause,
but they're both, they share quite a bit,
in that they were driven, I argue,
not by clever arguments
in the Supreme Court.
I mean, the people who
argued in the Supreme Court
were very good in both cases,
but it wasn't that they came
up with some new argument
and the court recognized, oh,
we were wrong for a long time.
They did tremendous work
outside of the Supreme Court,
outside of the federal courts,
essentially to shift public opinion,
elite opinion, political opinion,
so that an argument that
was unthinkable in time one
became thinkable in time two.
So on marriage equality, 1972,
a gay couple sued for the right to marry.
Their argument was considered so frivolous
that when it went up to the Supreme Court,
the Supreme Court rejected
it with a single sentence,
saying, doesn't present
any serious question.
We're not even gonna consider it.
1972.
Their arguments were it
violates equal protection,
denying same sex marriage.
- That is, the people bringing the case.
- The gay couple's arguments
were that it violates equal
protection and due process
to deny same-sex couples
the right to marry
that opposite-sex couples have.
Rejected out of hand, right?
2015,
those arguments went.
The same arguments, the legal
arguments didn't change,
and the court, you say, well
maybe the court changed, right?
Well, the court in 2015
was different from 1972,
but if anything, the court
in 2015 was more conservative
than the court in 1972,
which was sort of the
tail-end of the Warren Court,
the most liberal court
in American history.
So the justices, the court
didn't become more liberal,
the arguments didn't change.
What changed?
Well, the world changed.
And how did the world change?
It didn't just happen to change,
it changed because of a group
of committed individuals
who came together in organizations
like Lambda Legal Defense Fund or GLAAD,
which is a gay and lesbian
advocates and defenders in Boston,
or the ACLU's Gay and
Lesbian Rights Project.
And they worked together
to advance the ball in
an incremental fashion
using forums other than the Supreme Court,
because they knew they'd
lose in the Supreme Court,
using forums other than the Supreme Court.
Going to city councils, going
to progressive universities
and trying to get them to recognize
domestic relationships,
domestic partnerships,
whether they were
same-sex or opposite-sex.
Getting anti-discrimination laws
enacted in progressive cities
and then progressive states
that included discrimination
on the basis of sexual orientation.
Getting family law to be amended
in various incremental ways
to recognize the validity of gay families.
And only then did they go to courts,
and they went to state courts,
and they picked their states,
so they went to Vermont,
the most liberal state in the country.
Not saying anything about
California, but Vermont.
And they made arguments based only
on state constitutional law
that there was a right to marry,
because if they made an argument
based on federal constitutional law,
that could be reviewed
by the Supreme Court
and they knew they weren't ready
to go to the Supreme Court.
And they won civil unions,
which is not entirely marriage,
but it's a big step, in Vermont,
and then they took that same tactic
and went to Massachusetts,
got a right to marriage under
Massachusetts state law there,
took it to Connecticut, got it there,
Iowa, California, got it there temporarily
until Proposition Eight.
So it was a state-by-state
incremental strategy,
and only once there was a significant
critical mass of states that
had recognized this right
did they seek to make the
argument in the federal courts.
And the NRA did the same thing.
Not starting in Vermont and Massachusetts,
but Florida and Alabama
on the individual right to bear arms.
- Let's take the case of the
gay marriage equality decision.
All this political work
at different levels
in different forms, it
ultimately impacts ideas,
the idea of what is appropriate.
And you trace in there how the notion
that we shouldn't have gay marriage
because we don't like it,
we morally disapprove of it,
that gets dropped by the wayside.
But it's over time, as people come to see
that that's not a good argument.
And then the argument about love.
Two gay persons can love each other.
So as all this political
activity is going on,
ideas and thinking are changing,
and those ideas are
coming from a groundswell
in different forms and
in different places.
- Absolutely.
It was very much affected
by gay people coming out.
As long as gay people felt so oppressed
that they hid their sexual identity,
then many people didn't even know
that they knew anyone who was gay.
But once you protected
gay people sufficiently
that they could come out
and they started to come out
and it became accepted to come out,
then suddenly almost everybody
knew somebody in their family
or in their neighborhood
who was gay and out.
And it's much harder to demonize.
So the groups supported
those kinds of activities,
coming out, the politicization
of sexual identity
was an important part of the fight.
Public education was an
important part of the fight.
One of the groups that
I feature in the book
is an organization that all they did
was put pressure on Hollywood
and the television industry
and the news media
to portray gay people in a positive light,
not to portray them as sort
of some weird sexual
perverts or something,
but to portray them as
normal human beings,
which is what they are, after all.
And that was important also
to the evolution of an understanding,
the normalization, essentially,
of different sexual orientations.
I also talk about the way in which
the organizations learned
that in order to be effective
at communicating and
persuading the persuadables,
it was not so effective to talk about this
as a civil rights issue.
It was much more
effective to talk about it
as a love and commitment issue.
Because if you talked about
it as a civil rights issue,
then sort of the implicit message
is if you're against us,
you're like those racists and
those anti-immigrant people,
and that's not a message that's
likely to pull people on,
whereas if you're talking about it as,
these are people who love each other,
who are willing to make
a lifelong commitment,
shouldn't they have the same right
to have their relationships recognized
that two people of the opposite sex have?
Marriage is not about a right,
it's about love and commitment.
And that turned out to be
a very effective rhetorical strategy
to get people over.
And eventually popular opinion
was significantly in support
of marriage equality.
- The other chapter in
the book that struck me
is the NRA's effort
and success in winning
Second Amendment rights
for the individual,
and their luck on the political system
that emerges over time,
which in the present environment,
with the gun murders in
Florida just recently,
really helps us understand
how once a constitutional
right is recognized,
how difficult it is to
change the political system.
- Well, yeah.
The NRA is a fascinating study,
and for me, that section of
the book is in some sense
the most interesting.
They understand.
I think that the power of
the NRA is they understand
the democratic underpinnings
of constitutional rights.
We tend to think of constitutional rights
as being counter-democratic, right?
They're in the Bill of Rights.
Even if the majority wants to
tread on the First Amendment,
the courts are there and lawyers are there
to defend the unpopular.
But in fact, in fact,
if you can get the people
to support your right
and to understand your conception
as a right that's worth protecting,
you're in much stronger hands.
And what the NRA did was
use the power of democracy
to advance what they view
as a constitutional right
under the Second Amendment.
So for 100 years the courts had said,
there is no individual right to bear arms
under the Constitution.
But the NRA knew, we're not gonna be able
to file a case in federal
court and change that,
because the courts have said
the same thing for 100 years.
They don't tend to reverse
themselves very easily.
So instead they went to the states
and they went state by state.
They started off in Florida,
ironically, given what's
going on in Florida right now
in the wake of the high
school shooting there,
but they started in Florida,
which was very supportive of gun rights,
and then they take the victory there
to Alabama, to Mississippi,
all the way around the country,
so that by the time 2008 came around
and the Supreme Court was
actually taking up this case,
should the federal constitution protect
the individual right to bear arms,
the NRA had already made sure
that virtually every state in the country
recognized an individual
right to bear arms
by virtue of their own
state constitutions,
which had been amended or
interpreted to that effect,
or by virtue of state laws.
And the NRA didn't even stop there.
It also got Congress to enact laws
that recognized an
individual right to bear arms
and they got the executive
branch under George W. Bush
and under Attorney General John Ashcroft
to reverse its position
of many decades that there was not
an individual right to bear arms
and to reverse its position
so that it was recognizing
a Second Amendment individual
right to bear arms.
So by the time it went
to the Supreme Court,
the NRA had gotten the states,
Congress, and the executive
on board with the idea
there's an individual right to bear arms.
Well, at that point it's not that hard
for the Supreme Court to
come along for the ride.
But even so, even after
the court recognized that,
I argue that the most effective protection
or protector of gun rights in this country
is not the Second Amendment.
It's not the court.
It's the NRA.
Because they're able to stop
laws from getting enacted
that clearly would be constitutional,
and they're able to get
gun rights laws enacted
that are clearly not
required by the Constitution.
And they do it through their members.
They have five million members.
They have 15 million others
who say they're members
but don't pay their dues.
What one guy from the NRA told me was,
"We'd love to have their dues,
"but what we really want
is their identification
"with the NRA so that when we say act
"on this bill or that bill, they will."
And that's why, even in
the wake of horrific,
horrific mass shootings,
we see so little action
in the political branches.
- In a way, the NRA is
a movement, basically.
- Oh, absolutely.
- With clubs and so on,
and the notion that you're
gonna take something away
that I have mobilizes those people
when they get the word from the NRA
or when they read
what's going on in the newspaper.
There's another point that you make,
which is very interesting, and that is
that there is something
in the American ethos,
the political construct, the
myth of the frontiersman,
the individual, that in a way
the gun issue caps on that.
So it's almost a default
benefit, so to speak,
that they have when
they're making their case.
- Yeah, I think they're
appealing to the notion
of the rugged individual, the homesteader,
the person who goes out on the frontier,
takes a plot of land, grows some things,
and those people didn't have
anybody to protect them.
There wasn't a police chief in town,
and so they protected themselves.
And the gun is a stand-in for that notion
of rugged individualism, self-protection,
self-defense, really.
And that does play into, I think,
a particularly American
conception of the individual.
And again, particularly,
still today on the frontier,
in rural areas, much more
so than in urban areas,
where the populations
are overwhelmingly in
favor of gun control,
and understandably.
They don't feel that they
have to defend themselves,
because the police are there.
They're patrolling and hearing
the sirens all the time.
If you're out in the middle of nowhere
in Utah or Wyoming, the police
aren't gonna protect you.
So you feel like, I've
gotta protect myself,
and there gun rights
are very, very popular.
- So the question is,
can a social movement,
and we're seeing a new
kind of social movement
with high school students,
not only in the high school
where this horrific incident occurred,
but linking to other
high schools in the state
and maybe nationally,
can we hope,
or what is your perspective
on how that might change things?
Because this lock that the NRA has,
it's literally, they can target
a politician who votes against them.
- Yeah, so I think, look.
If you had asked me in 1991,
will the Supreme Court recognize
an individual right to bear arms,
I would have said, no way.
Because for 100 years they hadn't,
and the conservative Supreme Court justice
said the idea was a fraud.
That's not just, we won't recognize it,
but it's a fraud.
And yet 18 years later,
the Supreme Court recognized it.
And if you had asked me in 1985 or '90,
will the Supreme Court
recognize marriage equality,
I would have said, no, there's no way.
It's not thinkable.
And yet in both instances
what was unthinkable became thinkable
by virtue of exactly
what those high school
students are doing now,
which is political action
around a conception
of a right, of a sense of justice.
The question will be,
can that be continued?
Can it be multiplied?
Will it grow?
Right now it's got a lot of support,
and I think because it's high school kids
who can speak for themselves
and who are very sympathetic,
it could well grow.
And I also think because,
I would say Americans generally
are much more primed to
engage politically now
than they were before Trump's election
because of what Trump's
election signifies.
So the women's march on the
first day after the inauguration
was unheard of.
National, came up out of the blue.
National demonstrations
across this country,
in all kinds of cities and states,
even internationally.
And I think there's some
blend-over to this issue.
But gun control folks have a lot of work
to catch up to the gun rights advocates.
While the NRA was doing
this work all along
and doing it in the
states at the local level,
the gun control folks were
focused in Washington,
only focused on Congress,
not fighting the local
battles, and so they lost.
Mayor Bloomberg's Everytown for Gun Safety
is an attempt to mimic
what the NRA has done
and to build a local movement,
nationally coordinated local movements,
in favor of gun control.
And I think this could be
the beginning of that effort.
How successful it will be will depend
on to what extent people continue to fight
and to what extent the NRA fights back.
- One thing I would suggest
is that your book Engines of Liberty
be adopted by all the high
schools in the country.
- Oh, there you go.
A prescription for action, exactly.
- So in this last segment of the program,
you've described to us the job
you thought you were taking.
Hillary was gonna get
elected, so on and so forth.
We're now in a world
that's strangely different,
and it's kind of a transition
to a plutocracy in a way,
it appears generally.
And then there are all kinds
of social forces at work.
I listed some of them here.
Nationalism, which then says,
well, why should we pay
attention to international law?
Which is a linchpin of your book
on the rights of accused terrorists.
Libertarianism.
Dismantle the welfare state
and privatize prisons, basically.
So putting more and more people in prison
is a profitable undertaking.
Money and politics.
Thereby controlling the legislatures
with programs like ALEC, where legislation
is written in advance.
And then the whole issue of technology.
What is freedom of speech
in the context of Facebook's platform
and the intervention by external actors
to corrupt what we
think of as free speech?
How are you thinking about the big picture
now that your job description was wrong
with regard to what aspect,
which was the environment
you would be operating in?
- Right.
Well, that's a big question,
and a great question,
and one we ask ourselves
every day at the ACLU
and many other organizations as well.
I guess my sense is,
there are many troubling indicators,
and you've listed a bunch of them.
I think the vast disparity
between the rich and the poor today,
it's the second Gilded Age, is
a driver of so many of them.
But you see it in the
hyper partisan character,
you see it in the divided media,
you see it in the turn to populism.
You see it in the fact
that there is a sizeable
percentage of the American people
that are not embarrassed by Donald Trump,
but actually like Donald Trump.
These are troubling indicators,
but I guess I think what we need to do
is really twofold.
The first thing we need to do is we need
to defend the values that
this country was based on.
And those values are, among them,
basic human rights for all people,
which is a concept that
says everybody's equal.
There is not one set of
rights for rich people,
one set of rights for poor people.
That was my critique of the
criminal justice system,
is we're not living up to our ideals.
But at the ACLU, we fight to ensure
that our system does live up to its ideals
as best as we can.
And when a president
like Trump is in office,
many basic rights and
liberties are under attack.
Voting rights, reproductive freedom,
immigrants' rights, due
process, LGBT rights.
And he's chosen to attack all of these.
The first thing we need
to do is defend them,
and we are.
We told President Trump,
if you go down this road,
we'll see you in court,
that's our tagline,
and we have sued him in case after case,
and for the most part thus far
the courts have ruled with us.
They've enjoined the travel ban
directed at muslim countries.
They've enjoined the
transgender military ban
which President Trump
put in place by Twitter
without even consulting the
leaders of the military.
They've enjoined the ending of,
the termination of DACA, the
program for the young people
who came here, their parents
brought them here illegally
and are undocumented.
They have enjoined the Trump
administration's efforts
to block access to abortion
of young undocumented women
that they have in federal custody.
So in some sense we're
winning in the courts.
We're defending those
basic rights and values,
and that's part one,
but part two, I think,
is you gotta move beyond defense
and you have to appeal
to a positive vision.
And the positive vision, I think,
is that we are not a country
that has to be driven by partisan divide,
that has to be driven by hatred
and treating the other as
somehow less than human
or illegitimate.
We are a country at our best
that recognizes a set
of universal principles,
that recognizes that we are a community,
that recognizes that
we have an obligation,
not just to better ourselves,
but to protect others.
And that's what the
Bill of Rights reflects.
It reflects that conception.
And so we're trying to put
forth a positive vision
that people can come together and support,
people from the right as well as the left,
to move beyond this kind
of bitter partisan divide.
You know, whether we'll succeed
I think depends entirely
on the American people
and to what extent they continue to engage
in the defense of these
values at this time.
And so far I've been
encouraged by the real energy.
I mean, I haven't seen in my lifetime
this kind of civic engagement ever before.
I think the last time you saw
this kind of civic engagement
in America was the Vietnam War,
and that was in a time
when every young man
had a self-interest.
Now, it's not necessarily self-interest.
When people go out to
advocate for the DREAMers,
or when they go to the airports
to demonstrate against
the Trump travel ban,
they're not defending their own rights,
they're defending the rights of the other.
They're saying, these
rights are important enough
that we think they should
be extended to other people,
and we're willing to defend
the rights of other people.
I think that move is critically important
to offset the kind of self-interest,
pure private self-interest
which I think Trump embodies.
His narcissism embodies the extreme limit
of this kind of private interest pursuit
with no conception of public consequences.
- What about the extent
to which the judiciary
is being packed by people selected
by the Federalist Society?
Do you think that the power
of the ideas that will emerge
in the context of this
political opposition
you've just described,
do you think that when
they're in their seats
they will be impacted by it,
so the law will not go as far to one side
as one might expect if we're packing
so many conservative
justices on the court?
- The judicial appointments are a concern
because they last beyond
the administration.
If Trump does all kinds of things
by unilateral executive action,
which is mostly what he's done,
those can be reversed
by the next president
if the political will is there.
But if he puts people on the courts,
they're there for the rest of their lives,
and that can be generations.
That's definitely a concern.
A strong showing in the midterms,
supporting those who
believe in civil rights,
civil liberties, separation of powers,
the rule of law,
could lead to a Senate
that will put a check
on his putting in place
ideologues on the courts.
And that would be an important first step.
But I guess I would say,
sort of consistent with my
book Engines of Liberty,
don't focus solely on the courts.
We need to focus on the people
and on the power of movements,
and if those movements are powerful,
they will constrain the courts.
Historians have looked at
the Supreme Court's decisions
over time and correlated them
to public opinion on various issues,
and what they find is that
the court rarely departs
very substantially from public opinion,
and when it does, those
decisions tend not to last.
And so yeah, I'm very concerned
about court appointments,
but I think that just
underscores the importance
of people who care about civil
liberties and civil rights
engaging, engaging in the midterms,
but also engaging for the longterm.
- Let's talk a minute about
the free speech issues
that are raised in the
election, the use of technology,
of internet platforms,
to spread fake news.
It's not a question so much
of defending the right of
a Nazi to speak their piece
as it is a question about the
discourse is being corrupted
by untruths.
Not that I don't believe
in somebody else's truth,
but the whole purpose is to disrupt.
- Yeah.
This is a very vexing problem, obviously,
and we're only at the very beginning
of trying to figure out how to solve it.
I think were the will there
to disable bots,
these sort of automatic spreaders,
fake people,
that would be one way of checking,
of checking the reach of
these kinds of things,
'cause they rely very heavily
on this automated spread.
Because if you're sending something out
that's blatantly false,
the likelihood that it's gonna
be spread by normal people
is not very high,
but if you can spread
it through automation,
then the more people hear it,
the more they're gonna believe it
and then it will affect the debate.
So that seems to be one way.
Another thing that people talk about
is the extent to which,
how do you control fake news?
Should Facebook be in the business
of determining whether
your post is true or not,
in the same way that the New York Times
does fact-checking on its articles?
I'm not sure that that's
possible for Facebook to do.
If we're worried under the
First Amendment generally
about one concentrated
authority, the government,
having the power to determine
what's true and what's false,
and we are, and that's why we don't
let the government do that,
the government can't say, you
can't engage in falsehoods,
because we don't trust
the government to define
what's true and what's false,
then shouldn't we also be
worried about Facebook,
giving Facebook that power?
But at the same time it seems inadequate
to just say, let a thousand flowers bloom.
We'll rely on the marketplace of ideas.
Because the marketplace
has been so corrupted
by money, by automation, and the like.
I think it's a real challenge
for democracy and for
civil society going forward
to get a handle on how we
think about social media
as distinct from organized media.
- Well, on that note, David,
I want to thank you for helping us
think through some of
these thorny problems,
some of which we're still working on,
but others that have been
worked on in the past
you've given us an account
of how that was done.
I feel a responsibility to
show at least one of your books
to your audience.
This is the Engine of Liberty book.
I want to thank you very much
for being on our program.
- Thanks for having me.
It's been a delight.
- Thank you.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.